hello everyone I'm Laureen i'm jest and
welcome to house of horrors today we're
playing a very special game called never
mind it is currently in alpha I believe
or it's not publicly released some of
the memories of fun will be real while
others are false manifestation your
memories unrelated to their trauma use
the clues in the landscape mindscape
sorry to determine what actually
happened that's interesting once you've
collected all of the photographs you
must select which ones accurately tell
the story of the event alright so I fill
out a form cool a form that's fun i love
these kind of games i am 26 i'm feeling
a very like black may survive that's
cool yeah like that this is like eternal
sunshine for the game we're playing
never mind a game that also incorporates
use of a bio haptic heart rate monitor
sensor thing which i am wearing under my
clothes and I hope it kicks in I don't
have you read ohayo I feel like this
could be used for hassle Harlan general
oh my god we like take this should be
behind us we're at your eyes can we give
you money to rest picture yourself in a
calm face what the hell is with that
guy's be a face yeah looks like
someone's like a Miss painted it on yeah
it was so hot that day I remember being
so thirsty Oh Susie we're short over the
car what's going on why is your small oh
yeah that's grace should I test if like
the things looking my doing star jumps
again i want to say yes because i can be
doing Star Jones Lester yay gang's all
here dad in his weird dude I'm Isis easy
the dark you must kill the light that
sucks
Oh things got da bunny jerking there is
a key somewhere Oh on the other side of
the wall mommy's favorite drink was
growing up grape juice it smelled gross
okay so mommy's a drunken daddy killed
everyone nice alright let's try that I
think I that is the solutions that which
Leslie we can be realized through that
which has been left behind you okay yeah
so it's worth behind us so it's I like
that maybe the gun is the middle one the
first one is something in a field and
the last one is something about marriage
oh love not even lost one yes Ilana's
milk milk gun love may be okay I think
you sorry yeah yeah with the best oh she
didn't clap in front of microphone it's
what daddy and his letters he never
wanted to play off to the mailman
brought new one oh oh god what the
hell's going on here to know what I'm
looking for everything's scary down
it's being everything on scary Oh puzzle
bills no Canada's puzzle pieces on the
ground hey they like always turned away
from me to meadow well that's creepy as
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't want to stand in front
of I feel like it looks to me of you bad
chief kids I think if I get too close to
it yeah that nice that doesn't look like
it's going to be a nice puzzle sweet
good puzzling good job off hey the
statues are no wait is this a funeral
yeah cuz think so that thing is looking
at me oh Jesus kindly on his right man
see but don't scream mommy always wave
goodbye to Daddy when he drove to work
whoa whoa Nathan what that looks like a
place on we got it I want to bathing
worse what's this day shall be shopping
list make it all go away and a carton of
milk happy harm milk what is it bathing
was we rent before ah thanks guys what's
in it
I can push it 10 it yeah so we
definitely want to follow it oh we found
it Oh answer your back to go forward
that's very wise yes nah put that on our
poster well bloody milk don't want to be
done all right that's good I quite like
milk I know a lot of people don't that I
do I guess we're going out again oh
sweet i was outside huh oh look at all
the memories we collected oh what the
[ __ ] is happening in that cause weird we
is is like enemy we don't go huh Oh miss
Braga kids don't try this I don't try
this area custom artists is not endorse
real life Frogger ah you are going red
nose yeah
yeah he died in the car accident mommy
said she was so sad she hated questions
he's so did not die in a car accident
yeah that's low come back a little
picture maybe we followed the sound
no I think the sound good follow the
sound yeah oh [ __ ] noise puzzle that's
old school did he daddy
what's happening oh oh yeah we did do it
mmm Oh
yeah follow the sound oh yeah daddy
showed himself we knew that oh what the
hell man Oh what it was right odds
creepy okay okay so it's all truth lies
yep those eyes are following else yeah
come on no go away oh my god come on man
dad or the Tea Party Israel what she
wants oh she wanted to drink Jack she's
this is one since she wanted milk and
then mommy was busy oh oh [ __ ] well it's
the funeral this is about to get crazy
yeah it's about to get uncomfortable
just keep walking ahead oh it's a oh
geez I guess shrink Oh trial solution we
made so much progress you don't we go
shrink haha this Frogger game is
dangerous pick it up that's awesome you
excited that's not how physics oh yeah
oh here we go easy yeah we're the best
sorry enough momentum yeah seems like it
come on maybe I can cool water puzzle
that is cool two girls many ups thank
you for writing my head life [ __ ] me ok
I think I need one more cup so oh no I
think you're okay I think I just need to
be spaced out better cuz like those
stool right next to each other at the
top but then these have a massive space
in between so then just move that one
there for one or we can just leave it
because it might be working very fast
that you did I think I can take one out
no I don't think so oh no it's working
good you're good you're good hello yeah
you're all dead sorry steady
oh he had the gun in his mouth oh [ __ ]
okay that's the picture we needed I
think and then he shot himself well it's
a credible yes ok this is the game is
not complete ok that's cool yes greedy
we're in the credits the creepy they
said you can have whatever statue you
want I want to be shark huh just make me
a shark that's never mind which is
available from the website i think it's
never mind the game com thank you to
Erin for sending us the game and also
the heart monitor which I am wearing
right now he's totally been wearing it
um as usual let us know what you thought
about the game in the comments below or
if you have any other suggestions for
games that you'd like us to play or if
you're also an indie developer and you'd
like us to try to game and shake ass on
the stream other than that I'm sorry I'm
Jeff thanks for tuning in to house of
horrors will be back next week everyone
I
you